خروقات متعدده كسرت ما وصف بحصانه موسكو
فالمدينه التي اشبه بثكنه عسكريه عكرت
اجوائها مؤخرا مسيرات اوكرانيه عده وصادت
بعض زواياها رسائل عده حملها الهجوم
بالمسيرات على موسكو اولها دخول المعارك
مرحله الحرب النفسيه وتكتيكات توازن الرعب
لكشف نقاط ضعف الخصم كما يقول الخبراء
روسيا اتهمت الجانب الاوكراني بالهجوم على
مناطق مدنيه في عاصمتها مضيفه ان اوكرانيا
تتعمد الاستفزاز وتحاول ترهيب الروس كيف
من جهتها نفت التورط في الحادث مكرره
اتباع سياسه الغموض الاستراتيجي بشان ضرب
العمق الروسي هذه الاختراقات دفعت بضباط
روس سابقين لتاكيد ضروره انشاء روسيا
لانظمه تمكنها من رؤيه طائرات المسيره على
ارتفاعات منخفضه للغايه لكن مساحه روسيا
الكبيره قد تخلق ثغرات دائما هذا ورجح
خبراء عسكريون اوكرانيون اتمام الهجوم
الاوكراني المحتمل الاخير بطائرات من دون
طيار من طراز
علما بان موسكو تقع على بعد حوالي 500
كيلومتر من الحدود مع اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات